hello and welcome everyone it is june 28
and we are here in actin flap guest
stream number 24.1
today we're here with professor stephen
grosberg
and the
agenda will be as follows
first ali will provide a short
introduction
we will then play a 45-minute
pre-recorded video
followed by a q a so
thanks everyone for joining and
professor grossberg really appreciate
joining and i'll pass to ali for the
introduction
hello and welcome i'm ali i'm an
independent researcher from iran i'm
very happy and excited to be here and be
able to speak with uh professor
professor grossberg today uh so i'd like
to thank uh professor grossberg for
joining us
steven grossberg is the one professor of
cognitive and neural systems and a
professor emeritus of mathematics in the
statistics psychological and brain
sciences and biomedical engineering at
boston university
for more than 50 years he has led
pioneering research in discovering and
developing neural design principles for
autonomous adaptive intelligence based
on biological and machine learning
his neural network models have been
applied to many large-scale problems in
engineering and technology including the
design of increasingly autonomous
adaptive algorithms and mobile agents
in fact this is what carl fristen says
about him
whenever you claim to be the first to do
this or that in artificial intelligence
it is customary and correct to add with
the exception of stephen grossberg quite
simply stephen is a living giant and
foundational architect of the field
professor grossberg is the recipient of
the 2015 norman anderson lifetime
achievement award of the society of
experimental psychologists the 2017
frank rosenblatt award of the ieee
computational intelligence society and
the 2019
donald o'heb award of the international
neural network society
his latest book conscious mind resonant
brain as a combination of his
decades-long research written in a
rather non-technical and conversational
style is published in 2021 by oxford
university press
and is the winner of the association of
american publishers in 2022
pro's award for the best book of the
year in neuroscience
now i'll pass it to professor grootsburg
and then we'll continue with the
45-minute pre-recorded lecture
you'd like to say hi otherwise i'll
begin
the video i just saw my face frozen on
the screen
uh well i'm delighted to be here and
i hope you find some points of interest
in the lecture
and i'll look forward
to the q a ali has prepared a series
of questions that i've thought about and
have some prepared sketched answers and
then
after that if you're still
interested i'm happy to do
live q a
about anything related
to the topics of the day
okay
on to the main course
i will play the video
now
and you won't hear anything on the live
stream
all crop it and the audio will be coming
through fine now
hello
i'm delighted to be able to speak to you
today
about a topic concerning artificial
intelligence which as you know is very
much in the news these days
and i'll be contrasting
two very different approaches to
artificial intelligence but to do that
i need to pull up
my powerpoint
slides
and share them with you
and let me maximize them
and minimize my
face
so my topic today
is explainable and reliable ai
comparing deep learning
with adaptive resonance
this lecture is based on the following
article from this year
which
is both open access and on my web page
the article summarizes core problems of
deep learning
such as its untrustworthiness
because it's unexplainable
and its unreliability
because it experiences catastrophic
forgetting the article explains how
adaptive resonance
overcomes these problems indeed
overcomes 17 problems of deep learning
and outlines a blueprint for achieving
autonomous adaptive
intelligence
the article is part of a frontier's a
new robotic special issue about
explainable ai whose editors wrote and i
quote
though deep learning is the main pillar
of current ai techniques
and is ubiquitous in basic science and
real world applications
it is also flagged by
a.i researchers for its black box
problem
it is easy to fool
and it also cannot explain how
it makes a prediction or decision
in other words deep learning is not
trustworthy
no life or death decision
such as a medical or financial decision
can confidently be made based upon a
deep learning prediction
deep learning uses the back propagation
algorithm for learning how to predict
output vectors in response to input
vectors
back propagation was based on perceptron
learning principles that frank
rosenblatt started to introduce in the
1950s
it has a complicated history which
jurgen schmidt uber
beautifully reviewed in an article from
this year
major contributors include shinichi
amari paul werbos and david parker
perhaps one would say that it reached
its modern form with simulated
applications
in paul's
1974 paper
before being popularized 12 years later
by rommel hart hinton and williams
here's a schematic of a back propagation
circuit reprinted
from a survey article by gail carpenter
of neural network models
in it
information flows feed forward from an
input stage to an output stage
learning is supervised by an external
teacher who on each trial defines the
target or desired output
the teaching signal is the error or
mismatch between the actual and the
target outputs
the teaching signal in level f3
of adaptive weights in level f2
have no network pathway whereby to reach
from f3 to f2 within the algorithm
so the algorithm uses an artifice called
weight transport which physically lifts
the weights from here
and moves them there so that they can be
used to control learning
well this is clearly a non-local
operation
as well as being clearly
non-biological
back propagation learns through slow
learning which means that the adaptive
weights change just a little
to reduce error on each learning trial
that requires many trials that is to say
many repetitions of the whole database
to learn
possibly hundreds or thousands of trials
this is to be contrasted with fast
learning or adaptive weight zero error
signals on each trial just as we can
learn a face that we see just once and
remember it for a long time
if backprop tried to use fast learning
it would become
wildly unstable
catastrophic forgetting also occurs in
back prop so that during any learning
trial an unpredictable part of its
learned memory can unexpectedly collapse
so deep learning which is based on back
propagation is thus neither reliable
nor
trustworthy
but why is this
one reason is that all inputs are
processed by a shared set of learned
ways
the algorithm cannot selectively buffer
learned weights that is still
predictably useful
in particular there's no attention
mechanism
this problem occurs in any learning
algorithm whose shared weight updates
follow the gradient of the error
in response to the current batch of data
points
while ignoring past batches
there have been multiple efforts to fix
back propagation
one is to selectively slow learning on
the weights important for learning by
optimizing parameters using the bayes
rule as kirkpatrick at all
suggested a few years ago
but that assumes an omniscient observer
who can discover and alter
uh
the important weights
as well as non-local computations such
as the bayesian computation
the same problem occurs with
evolutionary algorithms
and diffusion based neuromodulation and
other approaches to try to fix back prop
these efforts to overcome catastrophic
forgetting
created additional conceptual and
computational problems
i view them as adding epicycles to
ameliorate a fundamental flaw in the
model
which to me is reminiscent of adding at
the cycles to correct problems in the
ptolemaic model of the solar system
as we all know the copernical model that
we now accept didn't require
epicycles this is why jeffrey hinton who
played a key role in developing both
backdrop and deep learning said in an
axios interview a few years ago that
quote he's deeply suspicious about
propagation
i don't think it's how the brain works
we clearly don't need all the label data
my view is throw it all away
and start
over
i would claim we don't have to start
because these problems were solved in
the 1970s and 1980s
in particular in the first issue of the
journal neural networks in 1988
i had an article that listed 17 problems
of back propagation
that are overcome by adaptive resonance
and here they are
with regard to not needing all the label
data
i noted in the third item here that
self-organized unsupervised or
supervised learning frees us from
needing labels all the time
as to slow
learning i noted that in art you can
have fast or slow learning
indeed ort can learn to classify an
entire database using fast learning on a
single learning trial as gail carpenter
and i showed in the 1980s
rover auto overcomes all 17 problems of
back propagation
without ex other cycles furthermore
all the core art predictions
have been supported
by subsequent psychological and
neurobiological data
indeed art is a principled biological
and technological
theory
unlike backprop and deep learning which
are just
algorithms
art has explained data from hundreds of
experiments and it's made scores of
predictions that have subsequently
received experimental support
well why has art been so successful
there are a number of reasons but one of
them is that art can be derived from a
thought experiment about a universal
problem in error correction
that i published 40 years ago in
psychological review
the thought experiment asks the question
how can a coding error be corrected if
no individual cell knows that one has
occurred
let me quote from my paper
the importance of this issue becomes
clear
when we realize that erroneous cues can
accidentally be incorporated into a code
when our interactions with the
environment is simple
and will only become evident when our
environmental expectations become more
demanding
and even if our code perfectly matched a
given environment we would certainly
make errors
as the environment itself fluctuates so
i was talking about autonomous local
learning
in a changing world
a purely logical inquiry into error
correction is translated at every step
of the thought experiment into processes
learning autonomously
in real time with only locally computed
quantities
moreover the thought experiment uses
familiar environmental facts
about how we learn as its hypotheses
and art circuits naturally emerge
where these facts are familiar because
they're you they're ubiquitous
environmental constraints on the
evolution of our brains
and since we're living with them all the
time they become familiar
because of this universality art
circuits may thus in some form
be embodied in all future truly
autonomous adaptive intelligent devices
whether biological or artificial
or it has probably for this reason
already been used in many large-scale
engineering and technological
applications
in fact almost immediately after art was
introduced
it began being used because it succeeded
in benchmark studies against machine
learning back propagation statistical
methods
genetic algorithms either getting much
better accuracy
or much faster training speed or both
it's also used in applications where
other algorithms totally fail
such as the boeing company's part
design reuse and inventory compression
application
that's just one of many large-scale
applications in engineering and
technology some of which can be found on
our tech lab webpage at bu.edu
the boeing parts design retrieval system
in particular was used to help design
the boeing 777
and to do that you needed fast learning
and stable memory to learn in search a
huge
and continually growing non-stationary
parts inventory
at the time of this application there
are already 16 million
one million dimensional vectors
that were used to
describe each of the parts and you have
to be able to quickly search the
inventory if you wanted to find a part
to use in a new plane
especially if your new design might have
a part in the inventory that was similar
to it
finding it and slightly modifying design
could save
millions of dollars in fabrication costs
satellite remote sensing is another
large scale application that art was
used for very soon and gail carpenter
and her colleagues took the lead here
for example using a very small number of
pixels of ground truth of 17 vegetation
classes
they used art to automatically complete
these
maps you are
using remote sensing data
art did it in a day
rapidly and automatically it gave a
confidence map for each pixel and the
pixels were 30 meters in scale which it
was small enough to see roads
this contrasted with an ai expert system
which took a whole year to do with and
it had to derive that
ad hoc rules from experts you have to
correct up upwards of a quarter of a
million site labels and even so the
pixel size was an order of magnitude
larger
gail went on with her colleagues to
study information fusion and remote
sensing let's say you have multiple
observers
each of them may be using different
labels the labels may also be incomplete
or missing or even incorrect and the
task was to derive
consistent knowledge from potentially
inconsistent data
to automatically learn and stably store
one to many mappings
and along the way gail and a colleague
showed how to self-organize a hierarchy
of cognitive rules including confidence
measures between these different levels
of the hierarchy
there's been continual work on arts a
more recent work was summarized in a
special issue of neural networks just in
december 2019
that was edited by donald lunch who
started this special issue with a
general overview of neural network
models that i and my colleagues
developed and then went on in a long and
detailed article with several
collaborators to provide a survey of
adaptive resonance theory neural network
models for engineering applications to
the present time
so back propagation and deep learning
are a feed forward adaptive filter but
art is more than that
in fact art is an
explainable
self-organizing production system
in a non-stationary world
what do these works mean
or it's self-organizing because it can
autonomously carry out
arbitrary combinations of unsupervised
or supervised learning trials with the
world as its only teacher
it's a production system because it uses
hypothesis testing to discover and learn
rules
by a top-down matching process that
focuses attention on
critical feature patterns these are the
patterns that predict behavioral success
while suppressing irrelevant features
or it's explainable using both its
activities or short-term memory stm
traces
and its adaptive weights or long-term
memory ltm traces
activation dynamics learning dynamics
observing the stm traces in a critical
feature pattern explain what recognition
categories will learn to code
and what features predict goal-oriented
actions
in particular the long-term memory
traces in the fuzzy arcmap algorithm
translate into explicit
fuzzy if-then rules that code what
combinations of critical features in
what numerical
ranges effectively control predictions
thereby illustrating one of many
examples where neural networks can learn
rule-based behaviors
art includes a bottom-up adaptive filter
or feed-forward neural network as i've
observed already but that's supplemented
by top-down learned expectations
and two types of recurrent inhibitory
feedback interactions that help to
choose the recognition categories and
the critical features
notably top-down expectations use what
gail carpenter and i call the art
matching rule to learn how to focus
attention on critical features that
control
predictive success
the art matching rule is another way of
talking
computationally about the process of
object attention
how we pay attention to salient objects
in the world
and we show how it stabilizes learning
and thereby avoids catastrophic
forgetting
remarkably and this has been supported
by many data
the art matching rule can be realized by
a top down
modulatory on center off surround
network well what does this mean
well let's say we have bottom-up inputs
from external features to feature
selective cells that gets stored in
short-term memory
let's say we activate a recognition
category which has previously been
learned and tries to read out
its learned
excitatory prototype
well it can't fully do so because it
also reads out an inhibitory off
surround that's broader than the
prototype
and so this is approximately one
excitatory against one's inhibitory it
can only give you a modulatory on center
but if you have both bottom-up inputs
and
the top-down expectations simultaneously
active
then within the bounds of the prototype
if you also have a bottom-up feature
you have two excitatory
against one inhibitory and
those features
can be selected gain amplified and
synchronized to start focusing attention
on this critical feature pattern while
outlier features the ones that aren't
within the prototype only have one
excitation against one inhibition or
suppressed
and in 1999 i was able to begin to
understand how laminar cortical circuits
carry out object detention
in particular layer six of a higher
cortical area
can activate layer 6 of a lower cortical
area
either directly or via lathe 5
and then
it can fold up the layer 4
to
modulate and on center
and to inhibit and off surround
so attention acts via a top-down
modulatory on-center off surround
network via folded feedback within
laminar neocortex
and this is one example of the paradigm
of laminar computing that i introduced
which has why are all neocortical
circuits organized in layers
and how do laminate circuits give rise
to all kinds of biological
intelligence
adaptive resonance enters the story
because attended feature clusters
reactivate their bottom of pathways
activated categories reactivate their
top down pathways
closing an excitatory feedback loop
between
features and categories giving rise to a
feature category
resonance that synchronizes amplifies
and prolongs system response between the
attended critical features and the
category to which they are bound
and it's this resonance that triggers
fast learning in the bottom up and
top-down
adaptive weights which is why i have
called the theory adaptive resonance
theory
moreover i've done a lot of work since
then showing that all conscious states
are resonant states and these feature
category resonances a one example of
that one that supports conscious
recognition
of visual objects and scenes
there's a lot of data support for our
predictions it's well known that
attention does have an on center off
surround
a circuit behind it and that attention
can facilitate matched bottom-up signals
many other data
as well
so now we can say more about why art is
explainable or trustworthy
in short-term memory it's because the
critical feature patterns determine the
attentional focus
that controls information processing and
you can just
read off what those features are
in long-term memory again it's the
critical feature patterns that determine
the adaptive weights learned by the
bottom-up adaptive filter and the
top-down learned expectation
so you know also what these weights are
encoding
or it's reliable and avoids catastrophic
forgetting because outlier features
that are not in the critical feature
pattern is suppressed
so that only the predictive features are
processed and coded
well it's a production system because it
carries out a kind of hypothesis testing
and this is nicely illustrated in the
simplest
art model called art one that gail
carpenter and i
published in 1987.
art one has an attentional system
that does all the category learning and
the expectation learning and the paying
attention
that interacts with an orienting system
which is activated when there are big
enough matches in the attentional system
and thereby drives a reset and search
for
novel or better matching categories
here's a schematic of the art hypothesis
testing and learning cycle
so let's say you have a bottom-up
feature pattern coming in there may be
many many active bottom-up features but
i'll draw just one
arrow here for simplicity
but that vector of input features can
activate a distributed pattern of future
detector cells some may be very active
some not so active some not active at
all
and as this is happening
each of these active pathways is trying
to turn on the orienting system so there
might be quite a few inputs converging
here
but as the features are activated each
of them tries to inhibit the orienting
system and there is many features as
there are inputs so this excitation
inhibition of balance keeping the
orienting system quiet as the feature
padding goes to the adaptive filter and
chooses a category
that category reads out to learn
top-down expectation that obeys the art
matching rule which can suppress some
mismatched features thereby reducing the
amount of inhibition on the oriented
system and raising the question when you
have too little
inhibition and too much excitation
how big a mismatch will activate the
orient system and cause reset
and that
uh ratio is determined
by what's called vigilance which i'll
say more about soon
but if you don't have enough inhibition
then the orienting system gets activated
it equally activates all the cells in
the category layer because it doesn't
know which cell may be active or not so
it causes a
novelty
uh sensitive non-specific burst of
arousal novel events are arousing
thereby selectively shutting off the
active category
eliminating its top-down expectation
and unmasking the original feature
pattern which can again go through the
adaptive filter
however now
this
previously disconfirmed category remains
off
and the category level is renormalized
so it responds to the same input pattern
with a new category and you go through
this cycle
of resonance and reset
until you get a good enough match
to either learn a new category or select
a previously learned category
and it's a theorem that as categories
are learned through this matching
process
search automatically
disengages
leading to direct access without search
to the globally best matching category
explaining for example how we can
quickly recognize familiar objects like
your mother's face even if as we get
older we store enormous numbers of
additional memories
so you don't have to start your whole
repertoire when you see mom you get
direct access and quickly say hi mom
there's a lot of support to the
hypothesis testing cycle
one source of support is from a ventral
aid potentials
also called human scalp potentials which
shows correlated sequences of three
different evoked potentials during
oddball learning tests
an experiment that john
paul ben k and i reported in the 80s
where you'll get a p120 for a mismatch
and then 200 for the arousal activated
by the ordering system
and a p300 for the short-term memory
reset of the category layer thereby
supporting the processing stages
of the search cycle
there was also physiological data from
infra-temporal cortex where categories
are learned early on
from the lab of bob desimone who showed
an active matching process that's reset
between trials during this kind of
event
there's also classical data about
hippocampal mismatch dynamics it's known
that novelty potentials subside as
learning proceeds from numerous
experiments this is as the orienting
system is disengaged
and there's more recent data using
multiple electrode studies from the lab
of errol miller
from prefrontal cortex
and simultaneous recordings in a
hippocampus
and they show there's rapid object
associative learning may occur in
prefrontal cortex which is a projection
of infra-temporal cortex one of the
stages of category learning while the
hippocampus may guide neocortical
plasticity for
by signaling
success or failure well this is just
what happens when the attentional system
interacts with the orienting system
there's also complementary computing in
art in particular the attentional and
orienting system was a complementary as
manifested by the fact that two
event-related potentials are
complementary processing negativity in
processing negativity
is activated when there's a top down
match in the attentional system
the m200 as i just noted is activated
when there's a mismatch that activates
the orienting system and you can just
look across these four rows
and see
that these
two
kinds of erp potentials are manifestly
complementary as
illustrator the complementarity of the
attentional and orienting systems
so this leads us to discuss another
paradigm introduced which i call
complementary computing
that asks what is the nature of brain
specialization
complementary computing introduces new
principles of uncertainty and
complementarity that clarify
why there are multiple
parallel processing streams with
multiple processing stages in our brains
and a beautiful example of that is this
famous image
of the macro circuit of the visual
system from david vanessa and his
colleagues where you can see these
multiple
uh parallel processing streams and the
stages needed to achieve what i call
hierarchical resolution of uncertainty
but what are complement
complementary properties their analogies
like a key fits into a lock or puzzle
pieces fitting together in words
computing one set of properties at a
processing stage prevents that stage
from computing a complementary set of
properties
these complementary parallel processing
streams are balanced against one another
it's a very yin yang kind of situation
and interactions between the streams
overcome
their complementary weaknesses
in fact there are many complementary
processes that are known in the brain
that have been modeled here is just
five of them there are many more
so this is a basic
principle of brain organization
so in summary so far back propagation
and deep learning do not have
thought to memory activation patterns
including
critical feature patterns so they can't
pay attention indeed they don't have any
fast information processing nor do they
have long-term memory top-down learned
expectations so they can't carry out
hypothesis testing using interactions
short-term and long-term memory traces
indeed there's no neural architecture
there's just an algorithm in this really
great contrast with complementary
computing which discusses the global
organization of our brains
from the very start it was shown how
easy it is to get catastrophic
forgetting and carpenter and i showed it
in art
when we would shut down the art matching
rule then we demonstrated you could get
catastrophic forgetting if you had just
four
input vectors a b c d
presented in the order a b c a d a b c a
d and so on
if they obeyed very simple
subset relationships
and here's a computer simulation of that
here you don't have the arc matching
rule
here's a b
c a d
a b c a d
and you see a
is coded by category one here
by category two here by category one
here two here it never settles down but
as soon as you impose the art matching
rule
learning is complete by the second trial
and after that point you get direct
access to the globally best matching
category
well let's say a little more about
vigilance
vigilance determines what features are
learned in the critical feature pattern
it clarifies how our brains learn
concrete knowledge for some tests and
abstract knowledge for others so in
particular high vigilance leads to
learning of narrow concrete categories
like a category that fires selectively
to a frontal view of your mother's face
low vigilance leads to learning abroad
and abstract categories like everyone
has a face
it should be emphasized that critical
feature patterns are explainable
at every
level of vigilance
it's known
from physiological experiments by
desmond again
that
their vigilance
control in the infra temple cortex which
they showed by studying easy versus
difficult discriminations
in monkeys
and in the difficult condition which
you'd assume would give you high
vigilance as expected you had
enhancement of the responses and
sharpened seal activity to the attended
stimuli
how is vigilance computed well let's say
of input vector
it instates a vector of
activities in feature detectors at the
same time as it tries to activate the
earning system but it this does so
multiplied by a parameter
row which is a sensitivity or game
parameter that's vigilance
and as these features get in state they
try to shut off the orienting system
and if the excitation is less than the
inhibition the orienting system stays
quiet
so the system can resonate and learn
but if inhibition isn't strong enough
the orienting system gets activated you
get reset and search for new categories
is a very simple computation because you
have an orienting system that's
complementary to the attentional system
well how do you change vigilance based
on predictive success
for this we have to go from unsupervised
to supervised art models
so we'll have
an unsupervised art a model an
unsupervised art d model
linked together by a learned associative
map as occurs in fuzzy arcmap and a key
point is you can have an input here
that can create an output there because
you have both bottom up and top down
connections at all these levels
so in this way you can learn many to one
and one to many
maps
one example of a many-to-one map is
let's say you're trying to categorize
visually processed
a letter a which comes in multiple fonts
you'll learn various visual
categories of a based on visual
similarity
at the same time you're learning
auditory categories for saying a
and then the associative map can
map all of these visual categories of
different a's to saying a
but it could have been here that these
inputs were symptoms tests and
treatments in a medical database
prediction
example and you're predicting length of
stay in the hospital
the possibilities here are endless and
then in many applications
or let's say
you're trying to figure out what this
image is and you've learned to say
that's a dog but today you say it's
rover and that causes a mismatch which
drives the search to focus attention on
the particular combination of features
in this door that will identify it as
rover that leads to learning of a visual
category of rover
an auditory category for the name rover
an associated map between them and you
can now simultaneously store expert
knowledge about that image
well how do you can jointly minimize
predictive error and maximize
generalization
so that you minimize
uh using um
memory resources let me read you an
answer
and then show what it means in images
match tracking realizes a minimax
learning principle
namely given a predictive error
vigilance increases just enough to
trigger search and thus sacrifices
the minimum generalization to correct
the error so let's say you've made a
prediction that must mean that vigilance
is less than the analog match between
bottom up and top down
but let's say now
you
have a mismatch well that'll lead to a
match tracking signal that bumps
vigilance up till it's just above the
analog match just big enough to drive a
search so you've given up the minimum
amount of generalization
to correct the error
well arc mechanisms like vigilance
control realized in laminar
cortical and phalanx circuits the answer
is yes my phd student max versace and i
showed this by developing the
synchronous matching art or smart model
which introduced a lot more
neurophysiological and anatomical verse
similitude
into the model including spiking
dynamics laminar cortical circuits
interacting with specific and
non-specific thalamic nuclei
this is another example of laminar
computing
and here's a schematic of the model you
see all the cortical layers with
identified cells a hierarchy of cortical
regions interacting with specific
thalamic nuclei and non-specific
thalamic nuclei
a ton of anatomical data got
functionally explained in this way and
many other data as well for example we
showed if you have a good enough match
between bottom up and top down you're
going to get fast gamma oscillations
during attention there was quite a bit
of data about that already but we also
showed if you have a big enough mismatch
you'll get slower beta oscillations that
wasn't well known
but since that time there have been
experiments in at least four labs in
three different parts of the brain
confirming that prediction
most important vigilance control was
shown
how to be uh controlled by mismatch
mediated acetylcholine release
a big enough mismatch
in the non-specific thalamic nucleus
activates nucleus basal minor
that
releases acetylcholine and layer 5 cells
across the cortex reducing after
hyperpolarization currents and causing
vigilance to go up
and i also showed that breakdowns in
acetylcholine modulation can help to
explain the symptoms of multiple
mental disorders
so as to memory consolidation we know
there's a dynamic phase of memory
consolidation
while the input exemplar still drives
memory search and before direct access
occurs but what if the orienting systems
cut out what if you have a lesion in the
hippocampus
well then
as occurs in medial temporal amnesia
you get unlimited anterograde amnesia
because you can't search for new
categories
you get limited retrograde amnesia
because you could have direct access to
previously learned categories this is a
failure of consolidation which is
mediated by the rna system you get
defective novelty reactions because that
is also
mediated by the orienting system
and memory consolidation novelty
detection mediated by the same structure
for the same
reason
there's normal priming because priming
occurs within the attentional system
learning of the first item dominates you
can get some learning but you can't then
search
and there's an impaired ability to
attend to relevant dimensions of stimuli
again because you can't
search
so now where does intra-temporal cortex
fit in within the larger brain
i introduced the predictive art or part
algorithm uh a model
in order to show how the prefrontal
cortex among other things learns to
control all
higher order intelligence you can find
that in a 2018 paper on my web page i
also published it open access
and in this macro circuit
these green areas of prefrontal cortex
control processes like working memory
learned plans
prediction optimized action
these regions in red control processes
like reinforcement learning emotion
motivation adaptively timed learning
the category learning i've talked about
in i.t
is just in those two regions all these
processes
uh control visual perception and there
are detailed models of all of these
regions and their interactions now
and each brain region in nature and in
predictive art carries out a different
function contrasting really dramatically
with the homogeneous organization of a
typical
deep learning network
so i've told you just a little bit about
some aspects of cognition and why
they're explainable
but if you put in all the biological
models of perceptual cognition emotion
and action they're all explainable
and then you can assert
how perceptual and cognitive processes
use art like excitatory matching and
match-based learning
to create
self-stabilizing attentive and conscious
representations of objects and events
that embody increasing expertise about
the world
moreover complementary spatial and motor
processes that i couldn't mention at all
use inhibitory matching and mismatch
based learning to continually update
spatial and motor representations to
compensate for bodily changes throughout
life
taken together they provide a
self-stabilizing perceptual and
cognitive front end
for conscious awareness and knowledge
acquisition
which can
intelligently manipulate the more labile
spatial and motor processes that enable
our changing bodies to act effectively
on a changing world
and when you put them all together they
provide a blueprint for designing
autonomous adaptive algorithms and
mobile
robots with behaviors humans can
understand and control because they're
both explainable
and reliable
see my webpage sites.vu.edu
or steve g
for these um
models
and with that i'd like to
thank you very much for your
attention
uh before we get started what i want to
say so
i should say that everything i've talked
about and much more
is in my book conscious mind resonant
brain
how each brain makes a mind to those who
don't know it's
self-contained and non-technical
it's written in a conversational style
so that people who know nothing about
the mind or the brain
can enjoy reading it and
i have friends who are a rabbi a
minister a
painter a gallery owner a lawyer a
social worker
who've all been enjoying reading it
also it's a big book it's almost 800
double column pages with over 600 color
figures so everything
is illustrated
but instead of costing a hundred fifty
dollars it costs
thirty 35
for the hard copy and only 17 for the
kindle because
i spent a lot of my own money
so that people who are interested in the
topic
can
read it and one other comment
if people
do have questions or comments
about my lecture or anything they read
in the book my email
is just steve
s t e e at
b-u austin university
dot e-d-u and i'll be happy
to try to reply so
thank you
now uh some researchers an explainable
ai people like lena de giovannia and
antonio di checo
demand that any explainable ai should at
the very least meet these four criteria
to be fair not biased in one way or
another to be accountable or reliable
to be secure against malicious hacker
attacks and not to be fooled easily
and also to be transparent now you
explained how adaptive resonance theory
or art and by the way i gotta say i love
your creative and clever use of acronyms
for your models
my favorite one is sovereign model
self-organizing vision uh expectation
recognition emotion intelligent
goal-oriented navigation if i'm great
amazing
anyway you explained how art can address
and overcome the issues of
accountability security and transparency
of current deep learning approaches
but it seems that this fairness issue
aka the problem of algorithmic bias has
also been a growing concern lately
especially since it's regarded by some
researchers like antonio badia as a
practically intractable problem so i
wanted to ask in what ways do you think
art can contribute to the
ongoing quest for mitigating this
problem
well when
um ali
sent me this question i said well first
i'd like you to
send me a definition of algorithmic bias
that
will clarify what you have in mind so
that i know what i'm trying to respond
to and you wrote me that you borrowed
the term from body's book the
information manifold
and you sent me a quote from page
that i will
quote in part before
i respond to that background information
so there are two main reasons for
algorithmic
approach to decision making that may
result in unfair outcomes either at the
individual or group level
one is that data used is biased and
another is that the
algorithm analyzes the data in such a
way that it yields biased results
the basic point to remember is that
algorithms are designed to achieve a
certain
goal not created naturally by evolution
or accident
thus most algorithms are written to
detect certain patterns of interest
for a particular objective not just any
pattern
to be able to pick out some patterns in
disregard others program is
build a model of the data by listing
expectations
about what data should be like in order
to qualify as relevant to the problem
well as i'll explain below
self-organizing learning classification
prediction models like adaptive
resonance theory or art overcome all the
problems
it's a general purpose device but why
don't i try to answer that
as part of my replies to
ali's subsequent questions
okay thank you so much
now uh
as you also mentioned in your lecture in
1988 you pointed out 17 issues with back
propagation in one of your
most famous and highly cited papers on
non-linear neural network
so
it's been 40 34 years now now do you see
any fundamental copernican change of
perspective happening in deep learning
research or we still keep uh we're still
keep adding epicycle upon epicycle to
our ptolemaic model
well you've sort of anticipated what i'm
going to say and as i said in my
lecture various investigators and i
mentioned
cloon
kirkpatrick and velas
have recently attempted to modify deep
learning to overcome some of his
problems but as ali just mentioned
my lecture noted that at least to my
mind they're like epic cycles
that are added to a kind of ptolemaic
model
of the solar system too it comes up
overcome some of his its problems
but as we all know
the ptolemaic model ultimately crashed
because it was both qualitatively and
quantitatively wrong
and they could only be solved by
throwing out the ptolemaic model
and replacing it with the copernican
model
that became the basis for modern
astronomy and astrophysics
so art overcomes foundational deep
learning problems
that can't be solved using epicycles and
had already
done it
shortly after i introduced it in 1976
and i it can't be over emphasized
as i noted in my lecture deep learning
is untrustworthy
because it's not explainable
and it's unreliable
because it can experience catastrophic
forgetting
and that happens for a basic reason deep
learning just like backprop
which is its learning engine is just a
feed forward
adaptive filter
so as you know in your question i
describe these two problems in addition
to 15 others
in my offsited article that i published
in 1988 in the first issue
of neural networks
and i also showed them that art
had already solved the problems in 1976
and
what i find
sad
is that back propagation and deep
learning architects like jeff hinton
who knows all of this background
never mentioned his history
um
and keep talking about making deep
learning explain
the brain
but it can't explain the brain because
its foundation
is contradicted by basic
psychological and neural
data yes
great in the deep learning community
i like comparative discussion
and criticism
but i don't like solipsism in science
great thank you
now uh
on slides
number 50 of your presentation you
pointed out that
art is inconsistent with models where
top-down matches suppressive such as
bayesian explaining away
a similar view is evident on page 195 of
conscious mind resonant brain
to which you also add one of many
serious problems
of the bayesian models is that fully
suppressive matching circuits cannot
solve the stability plasticity dilemma
now would you care to further
elaborate on this point
sure um
my lecture and my book summarizes
uh
my book
my lecture couldn't go into a lot of it
some of the copious
psychological anatomical and
neurophysiological
evidence
expectations
which obey what
uh gail carpenter and i call the art
matching rule
are matched against bottom-up input
patterns
and as the lecture briefly noted the art
matching rule is defined by a modulatory
on center
off surround network
and the modulatory on center is
excitatory however acting by itself
it can't fully excite its target cells
it can prime them sensitize
excuse or modulate them
to be ready to fire vigorously when
matched bottom-up inputs
arrive
and when there is a good enough match
between the bottom-up inputs and an
active
top-down expectation
that's reading out a circuit that obeys
the art matching rule
that's when you get what i
noted in my lecture
what i call a feature
category resonance because it develops
between the matched or intended features
and the recognition category
that they activate
and it's this resonance that
synchronizes and gain amplifies
the match speech as well
suppressing the mismatch features
and that sustained
resonance is important because it's
sustained long enough to drive learning
in the more slowly varying adaptive ways
of the active
bottom-up filter
and learn top-down expectation
it's because resonance triggers learning
that i call the theory adaptive
resonance theory
and the art matching rule avoids
catastrophic forgetting as i briefly
mentioned
in the lecture because it suppresses
irrelevant features
using its off surround while it's
amplifying and focusing attention
on the critical features
that regulate both bottom-up and
top-down learning
as well as
successful predictions
because they're relevant they've been
selected by previous
learning experiences
to which discover the set of features
that are predictive or causal
in a given situation
and along the way
not only does the art matching rule
achieve causality and predictions
although
as the world changes you have to update
your
causal explanations it also solves the
stability plasticity dilemma
in brief purely suppressive matching
can't do any of this
it shuts off the expected data
and so it can't focus attention or learn
about it
and um
there is fully suppressive matching
in
a spatial and modal learning
but that isn't learning
to be expert
about the world
i could explain that more if you want to
know but
that's also in my book and these two
kinds of learning
the
excitatory match-based learning and the
inhibitory dispatch learning
are computational complementary it's
another example
of complementary computing and
the match based learning goes on in the
ventral or what cortical stream and the
mismatch learning
goes on in
the where or
dorsal cortical stream
the watch stream for perception and
categorization and prediction
the where stream for spatial
representation and action and then
you need what to wear and where to what
interactions
so that you can
reach for and otherwise engage through
approach and what have you
look at reach for
approach
to things that you've recognized
thank you now following from the
previous question and uh considering
that the free energy principle and
active inference framework as works in
progress are related to predictive
coding and bayesian brain hypothesis
what is your view on the extent of
compatibility between art and active
inference
because despite some prima facie
similarities between the two
do you see them as fundamentally
incompatible or irreconcilable
and how could this
how could this issue be rigorously
evaluated and positively resolved in
terms of reconciliation or integration
of art and act and active inference or
otherwise because you see
to add some more context here um smith
smith at all in their recent paper and
active inference approach to modeling
structure learning
uh have stated that although they are
they have not explicitly incorporated
arts
top-down attentional and feedback
mechanisms
there are mechanisms within their active
inference-based model which they believe
are quite similar to top-down and
bottom-up feedback exchange in art so
there's a seems to be some degree of
disagreement about
the compatibility between the two
frameworks
well let me try to
respond to the two parts of your
question separately
so i'm not going to try to talk about
smith at all for a moment
um
let's talk about free energy and i like
getting definitions on the table
because it's really so frustrating to
try to remember what something is when
someone's talking about it
so i go to wikipedia
wikipedia writes in part that the free
energy principle asserts quote
that systems minimize the free energy
function of their internal states
which entail beliefs about hidden states
in their environment
the implicit minimization of free energy
is formally related
to variational bayesian methods and was
originally
introduced by carl fristen as an
explanation for embodied perception
neuroscience
where it's also known as active
inference and we all know
paul is a brilliant
and very insightful man
the free energy principle describes the
behavior of a given system by modeling
it through a markov
blanket that tries to minimize the
difference
between their model of the world
and their sense
and associated perception
this difference can be described as
surprised and is minimized by continuous
correction of the world model
of the system
uh one more part of the quote the free
energy principle has been criticized for
being very difficult to understand
each and even for experts
and the mathematical consistency of the
theory may have been questioned by
recent studies
discussions of the principle have also
been criticized for invoking
metaphysical assumptions
far removed from a testable scientific
prediction
making the principle on
falsifiable
and in a 2018 interview fristen
acknowledged
that the free energy principle is not
properly
falsifiable
so that's fristed himself
so my main concern with the free energy
principle just like any theory about how
brain makes a mind is
how much data can it explain
in a principle and unifying way
that's what we do in science we
develop theories to explain and predict
data
and in the case of the free energy
principle from what i can see
the answer is essentially no data and
you can correct me from wrong
it therefore cannot be evaluated as a
physical theory at all
and there's a basic reason for this
problem
our brains are designed to autonomously
learn in real time
in response to a changing or
non-stationary world that's filled with
unexpected events like today
we're experiencing an unexpected event i
didn't know till recently that i'd be
enjoying your company today
optimization principles were designed to
cope
with stationary dynamics whose rules and
probabilities do not change through time
so it's not possible to quote minimize
the difference between their model of
the world and their sense and associated
perception unquote
because there is no predefined model of
the world
which is always changing in unexpected
ways so you need a theory about
how the world changes
surprise occurs in art when there's a
big enough
mismatch
between an input pattern and the
currently active
top down expectation of a category that
it's activating
this mismatch activates the art
orienting system that i briefly
discuss in my talk which interacts with
the attentional system
where the category learning doesn't
occur
and as i illustrated in our discussions
of search and vigilance
that it drives hypothesis testing or
memory search
to discover a better match or to begin
to learn a new category
so auto discuss a better match in the
case where
the system was attending some other
familiar features when the new input
occurs
but the features of the new input have
previously been categorized that's why
they're familiar
and then the orient system very quickly
shifts attention
to the matching category and you
resonate on and you recognized it
consciously often
art begins to learn a new category when
the input represents
a truly unfamiliar and novel situation
now as to bayesian methods in science
hey i'm a mathematician
how can i not love days right
but the beauty of bayes is its
simplicity
you just write the probability of two
events a and b in two different ways
the probability of b given a times the
probability of a
the probability of a given b times the
probability of b
set them equal because they're identical
divide by let's say probability they and
then optimized
that's base
and it's a useful statistical method and
should continue to be used in statistics
but it's just the formal identity
wherein lies its power
it says nothing about any physical
reality
whether in physics chemistry or biology
today's rule itself tells us nothing
about physical reality
and contains no heuristics to discover
anything about physical reality
but that you need to develop models
driven
by a profound analysis of large
databases
so it turns out that biological models
like god do not
incorporate the bayes rule however
art does routinely
choose the best or optimal categories
that represent the database
so you don't need base to achieve
optimality
also base works best in a stationary
world with stationary probabilities
and arts designed
to learn about a non-stationary world
so you know one can discuss this till
the cows come home
uh it's good for what it was designed
for
um
and some of the neuroscientists who try
to apply bays
are wonderful experimentalists
but they know no myth and no theory
and
you know
it's uh
the temptation of a free lunch
there it is waiting to be applied
there is no free lunch in science
thank you
uh
now
as a final point of comparison uh what
are the smith i didn't reply to yes
yes
okay you quoted a sentence of smith
but
before that said smith at all wrote
it is also worth highlighting that as
our model is intended primarily as a
proof of concept
and a demonstration of an available
model expansion reduction approach
that can be used within active inference
research
it does not explicitly incorporate
some aspects such as top-down attention
that are of clear importance to
cognitive learning processes
and that have been implemented in
previous models for example
the adaptive resonance theory rock model
gross word was designed to incorporate
top-down attentional mechanisms and
feedback mechanisms
to address a fundamental knowledge
accusation problem
the temporal instability of previously
learned information that can occur
when a system also remains sufficiently
plastic to learn new and potentially
overlapping information
while our simulations do not explicitly
incorporate these additional
complexities there are clear analogs
to the top down and bottom up feedback
exchanges and within our model
such as the prediction and prediction
error signaling
within the neural process theory
associated with active entrance
art addresses the temporal instability
problem primarily
through mechanisms that learn top-down
expectancies that guide attention and
match them on bottom-up input patterns
which is quite similar to
the prior expectations and likelihood
mappings used with an active inference
but as i've already noted the quote
prior expectations and likelihood
matching mappings within adaptive
inference quote unquote do not have any
of the key learning attention and memory
stability properties of the york
matching rule york matching rule is
unique solution to that problem
in its variations
it's been supported by
psychological anatomical physiological
and biophysical data
it also occurs in many species
nobu sugar for example shows it occurs
in bats
it occurs in ferrets
you know
so also i think it's important to know
that when learning begins in an arc
model it doesn't need
prior expectations or likelihood
in fact typically the initial
bottom-up weights are chosen to be
random
because you don't know what you're going
to be experiencing and the initial
top-down expectations are chosen to be
large
so that whatever category happens to be
learned when it reads out its top down
expectation
it can match whatever features activated
that category
so they all start larger than their
pruned
to match the critical features that
happen
to be learned in that category
so there are no
built-in models
or discovers its own models
i should also emphasize that active
entrance is also not
explainable
arts is explainable because
a currently active critical feature
activity pattern
namely the features to which attention
is paid controls
all
learning and prediction by the model and
in principle
can be measured by neurophysiological
experiments
a model without cell activities or
short-term memory traces
that can represent the critical feature
pattern
can't be explainable
so i think there are qualitative
differences
i don't say people shouldn't use active
inference
it may be incredibly useful and powerful
in technological applications
but when one is doing
you know
brain science psychology
it just doesn't match under foundational
data
it just doesn't
more personal
thanks
and uh i guess you'd
somehow already answered a part of this
question but
uh what are the possible ways in which
an arts approach to explainable ai
which if i'm not mistaken can be
described as a modern dependent
intrinsically explainable approach
can inform active inferences approaching
cross-fertilize with it which is based
on abductive reasoning through
constructing generative models for
example
as i sketched out in par and patzulo's
understanding explanation and active
inference paper
well first um
i i don't think art is model dependent
uh as i just noted one begins typically
the learning out with random
initial bottom-up weights and uniformly
distributed
drop down initial adaptive weight so you
can match any category that you happen
to learn
but the authors you quoted write in part
that active entrance and here i want to
quote them
so we i can respond in
a little more detail
active entrance quote implies a deep
generative model
that includes a model of the world
used to infer policies and a higher
level model that attempts to predict
which policies will be selected
based upon a space of hypothetical that
is down to factual explanations
and which can subsequently be used to
provide
retrospective explanations about the
policies pursued
so again artworks without a generative
model of the world
or any predefined policies
uh
of course what it's trying to do is
discover
what changing world it happens to be in
and nobody knows what it is
at priority
and in general in our classifier
responds
to a front end
of pre-processes
that process perceptual data from one or
another sense
notably vision and audition where we get
most of our information about the world
um
and that's why classifier like art
begins its work in the brain
in the temporal cortex
where it received highly
pre-processed perceptual representations
so um
or decades of work went into
understanding our brains consciously
seeing here
and in the case of vision art
classifies perceptual boundaries and
surfaces that require
multiple stages of processing
because as i mentioned briefly they
or the outcome of what i call
hierarchical resolution of uncertainty
you need multiple stages
to define a perceptual boundary surface
one reason being because our sensory
organs
register such noisy and incomplete data
like you may know
that our photosensitive retina
has a huge blind spot
where you can't register any
sense any visual signal the blind spot
as big as the fovea
where all of our high resolution
vision occurs so it's not a little thing
and we're moreover veins
come out of the fovea and occlude the
retina in multiple places
and you can't
register visual signals on the veins
either so
the signal you're getting is very
incomplete and it takes
multiple processing stages
to overcome those uncertainties and
my college and i've worked for decades
to explain
how that happens
um
maybe i'll stop after that
thank you so much
now uh this next question is of a
personal interest to me
because currently i'm working on
modeling some probabilistic aspects of
affective response to music and
your most recent paper toward
understanding the brain dynamics of
music
immensely helped me gain a better
understanding of entrainment
as you pointed out in the supplementary
notes for this paper
violation of prior learned expectations
is instrumental in inducing a wide range
of effective responses in musical and
non-musical situations
uh some psychologists such as patrick
usland have distinguished between
perception and arousal of emotions
interrupt you but you left out a
question
is it the lack of time where you just
skipped it accidentally because i want
quite a bit about it
how do you see the future of art and
neuro and spider
i think that will be our last question
okay so we'll come back to that
yes yes thank you
because that that's an important
question to me yes okay so sorry to
interrupt i just want to be sure no
problem thank you
now uh yes um
well some psychologists such as patrick
guslin have distinguished between uh the
perception and the arousal of emotions
in the context of musical experience
and also several studies such as the
works of justland and gabrielson from
the psychology department of uppsala
university
have shown that despite music's ability
to communicate a wide range of
positively and negatively balanced
emotions
it somehow evokes mostly positively
valenced emotions uh for instance we can
easily perceive uh rage or anger in
music without necessarily getting angry
on the other hand we're more likely to
actually feel elevated and happy after
listening to happy music
and also the evidence shows that this
disparity between perception and
evocation of mu of emotion
is probably even more significant in
musical experiences than
any other non-musical experiences
so how can this difference in diversity
between perceived and
aroused aroused or evoked musical
emotions be account and be accounted for
within art
framework can it possibly be regarded as
another kind of broken symmetry as you
mentioned on page
621 of your book
but specific to musical effects
so um
as you've noted i haven't studied this
issues in the context of music but i'll
try to venture some general comments
i should first note that the laminar
model
which is
a development of art to show
how and why all neocortical circuits
that support perception and cognition
typically share a canonical
six-layer circuit
my colleagues and i have modeled how
just as in our brains variations of this
canonical laminate circuit can support
all
perceptual and cognitive
processes so there's a major
generalization of art
and we've done it for vision speech and
cognitive working memory
and planning in particular
so the main point is that the
laminar circuitry is basically in all
perceptual and cognitive
areas vision auditions etc etc that's
how
one can create a context for discussing
music and in fact my work on music
applied
such discoveries like
i was able to put together
discoveries that had been made
based on
if what i believe were different
evolutionary pressures upon
the organization of our brains but that
evolution also discovered and i try to
sketch how if you put some of them
together in a certain way
then
capacity
for
learning and consciously performing
music
book could arise
so now how about arousal
well it's essential of course for all
awareness and consciousness
your cortex needs to be
adequately aroused for waking
consciousness
to occur at all it also arouses and
plays a major role in the processing
of emotions and is very relevant to
musical
issues
because my gated dipole model
explains how opponent processes
opposites
are organized in all parts of our brain
are perceptual cognitive motor
affective
in particular emotions are organized
in pairs
in such an emotional dipole
and one reason is because emotions need
to compete with each other
such as fear versus relief
for example in post-traumatic stress
disorder therapy
a therapist may try to help a patient
to think about positive experiences
that generate relief
in order to inhibit the chronic fear
that's so destabilizing during ptsd
so their
opposites are competing
and another property that arousal
enables is that
the sudden offset of an emotion like
fear
let's say during escape behavior
let's say you know a favorite example of
mine is
you know some cruel experimentalist puts
the pigeon in the skinner box
the floor is electrified
the uh pigeon is feeling pain and fear
it's
dashing frantically around trying to
keep its feet off the floor
it bangs into a red buzzer
the buzzer shuts the shock off
and
the animal experience the wave of relief
or positive motivation
for learning the escape response
so
the rebound from theater relief
that can be associated with actions that
lead to escape and can motivate escape
by means in the future
is energized by arousal in the gated
dipole
you shut off the external cue of shock
but the arousal is tonically or
has sustained activity in both the fear
and elite
channel so
because the arousal is sustained or
tonic through time
and equally activates the fear and
relief channels
when fear suddenly decreases
then arousal in the relief channel wins
the competition
and can thereby call what i call an
antagonistic rebound
from theater relief that activates the
relief channel
and thereby providing
motivation for escape
uh whether reactive or learned
uh through escape experiences
and i also approve which is related
to some degree of music that
the non-occurrence of an expected event
can by itself cause
a burst of arousal and thus an
antagonistic rebound
and can
flip emotions from positive to negative
in so doing
and i always loved that discovery
because
i especially love discoveries where
the occurrence of nothing has profound
effects on
future behavior
so it's the non-occurrence of the
expectation cause of this mismatch
that can flip
emotions
now how this influence of the perception
of music
needs more work it's
as i mentioned my paper i haven't
tried to study
that
uh
my
my paper on music i feel is like
you know a drop in the bucket and
hopefully if i don't get around to it
someone else will
but the above examples show that arousal
and emotion
are not the same thing cause arousal
can support all emotions
fear relief hunger satiety whatever
the ones that win the competition
are then able
to support compatible behaviors by
motivating them
and i've also explained that the level
of arousal must be chosen
within an intermediate range
to support normal behaviors it's a kind
of golden
mean
there's an inverted view
on the effects of having arousal from
too little or too much
and if you have too little arousal
you have an underarouse syndrome
which can support
symptoms like autism
and
over arousal can support
symptoms of abuse like schizophrenia is
only one of many factors in these
diseases
but i'm happy to say that subsequent
clinical data supported those
predictions that
these two mental disorders are at the
opposite speed
of the arousal inverted view
so i think and you know this very
speculative because i've never really
seriously studied it and i
try not to speculate but what the hell
oh the kind of arousal that music
activated generally positive just like
the arousal that activates exploratory
behaviors is positive
it somehow links
that you know music is a
a sonic adventure if you like
there's no aversive cue when listening
to music except perhaps
music that played so loud as to cause a
headache or
ear damage or even a seizure
insusceptible in the individual stuff
there's no particular reason why it
shouldn't be
um
uh
positive
so now which question you wanna ask me
uh i think we're left with just two
other questions
if
yeah well not too tired starts where
there's a final point of comparison
another starts on a more fearless
yes uh the last where and the last
the two questions
so you want to
uh how do you see the future of all
ignorance by their research
and before that yes before that uh i
just wanted to
ask you about the um your view about
artificial consciousness uh do you see
i really need the first answer to answer
the second question okay as you wish yes
okay so
so yeah uh and how do you see
yeah
yes it's quite fine and uh how do you
see the future of art and brain inspired
ai research in general uh in your view
what research areas ought to gain more
attention than they do today
so i'll give you quite a general answer
but it implies
what i think about this
so first with a caveat i like to say i
couldn't predict the present so i can't
predict the future
that being said i believe that all
engineering technology and ai
will increasingly embody
autonomous adaptive intelligence
in the coming century and we can already
see its beginnings
in autonomous automobiles and airplanes
and increasingly
autonomous controllers on the factory
floor and many people
have written about it
and i think art will play a central role
in this as well as other models
that are summarized in my book and
that's
because already in 1980 i published
a thought experiment
in the journal psychological review
which was then and still
probably remains the leading theory
journal in psychology
and you may recall that einstein derived
both special relativity theory and
general relativity
from thought experiments and
let me just
clarify by my thought experiment wherein
they derive
their enormous power
so my thought experiment was about how
any system
can
autonomously it's all about autonomy
correct predictive errors in a changing
world
and the hypotheses upon which the
thought experiment were derived
are just a few facts that are familiar
to us all
from daily life
and they're familiar because they
represent ubiquitous
environmental pressures on the evolution
of our brains over the millennia
and when they act together
i suggest art is the unique outcome
that's a huge
claim
and
i turned to the power of the thought
experiment not any personal ego trip
for that belief
in particular nowhere in the thought
experiment of the words mind or brain
mentioned
so if you
accept that these facts about the world
exist which we all do
and that they're always operating on us
then you have to accept the outcome if
you believe
in the scientific method and logic
so art is a universal solution
to the problem of autonomous
error correction and changing world
so in another way if you can't find a
mistake in the thought experiment
then i think
you either have to believe
in art like dynamics may be expressed in
laminar or
your favorite art variant
or you have to give up your belief in
logic and the scientific method
it doesn't imply that art can't be
further developed
i expect a large number of scientists
technology and technologists to be busy
developing what's like
architectures long after and gone
so maybe now we can go to your
philosophical note with that background
yes thank you so much
now uh
yes uh as i mentioned i mentioned
earlier uh i just wanted to ask about
your review about your v1 artificial
consciousness
do you see the consciousness as
artificially producible or engineerable
as some researchers like mike sormsley
is there a fundamental distinction
between a biologically conscious agent
and an artificial agent with a fully
simulated computational model of
consciousness
i know it's a big big question but i
couldn't resist asking your opinion as
an authority on consciousness modeling
i'm happy to give it a shot
so
as i just noted
my work on art suggests it solves the
universal problem
about how we can learn to correct
predictive errors in a changing world
my work also shows in its analysis
of hierarchical resolution of
uncertainty remember like how you go
from some a noisy retina
to a surface representation that can
control looking and reaching
uh how evolution may have been driven to
discover
conscious states
so this was a surprise to me too
conscious states were needed in order to
choose
that processing level
the levels that computes
a sufficiently complete
context-sensitive and stable
representation in the case of vision
surface representation
with which to successfully plan and act
to realize value goals
but let me make it
clear
so you start with a noisy red and you
have to go
up all of these stages until
you get a sufficiently complete
surface and boundary representation that
you can use
to regulate successful action
and if you used one of the earliest
stages
it would lead to incorrect actions which
would
kill you off by governing selection
so how the hell do you know
where the stage is where you can
compute the sufficiently complete contra
extensive
and stable
one
and i sh propose in vision i predicted
that the choice is embodied in what i
call a surface
shroud resonance
between pre-strike visual cortical area
v4
in the next processing stage
posterior parietal cortex or ppc
so it's in v4 you get this really good
surface representation
and then a resonance
between the surface and spatial
attention which fits the surface
that spatial attention and ppc
is called a shroud christopher tyler
gave it that name
the surface route resonance
allows you to
pay conscious
spatial attention to
the surface that you're going to use
to control looking and reaching
behaviors
so it's a way of ensuring you have a
good enough representation to control
action
so
the shroud is computed in posterior
parietal cortex
which is part of the dorsal or
where cortical stream
and the shroud modulates
invariant category learning in the
ventral
or what cortical stream
i can't go into that right now but my
book discusses it
the category learning itself in the what
cortical stream as i indicated
is supported by a feature category
resonance
and so
the surface shroud resonance is
modulating in varying category learning
uh in the future category resonances
surface shroud resonance also supports
conscious seeing
the future category resonance is
supporting
conscious recognition
and when they synchronize the course
streams
on a familiar object
that's when you consciously see
something that you know about
okay so
conscious states hereby arise due to
learning
requirements
this sort of fell out of the wash
of
how you do invariant category learning
and learning in particular without
catastrophic forgetting it's regulating
feature category resonances
so given that the above solutions are
computationally universal
in the sense i sketch
the self-organizing machine that
embodies them
should be able to support internal
representations whose parametric
properties mimic conscious states
well whether such a machine can
experience conscious qualia
remains as much of a mystery the
machines as it does
to humans
and that's because no computational
theory which after all is just a set of
equations
uh can't do more than imitate the
dynamics of our brains perhaps with
great precision
i don't have a clue
why
the
representations that my colleague and
i've worked so hard to explain huge
amounts of psychophysical data about
seeing
extra shading
3d form
[Music]
just go through the list
why they support qualia
i don't know
they ask god
or whatever god you
choose to believe in in the 21st century
thank you so much professor um i think
we have a couple of questions in the
chat but uh we are actually approaching
our two-hour limit i don't know daniel
if uh
it's a good place to stop or
whatever you say
i think that's a great place to stop
you've given us a lot to
to think about and digest
and i hope that these words are
taken well and paid attention to might
create some categories activate some
categories
um but professor grossberg thanks again
for this amazing live stream we really
appreciate it i appreciate it i'm
depending on younger people like
yourself
that do just what you said daniel i'm
not going to be around that much longer
so um
i i hope you have
whether with my work directly or related
work you have a very
fulfilling intellectual adventure i know
i've been on a wild ride since i was 17
and
that's 65 years of discovery and
i've loved every minute of it
thank you very much
see you soon
thank you
it was really pleasure meeting you thank
you
thank you
so you'll tell me when i'll see this
right
somewhere on youtube awesome
you